I'm dr. Brady Barr as a herpetologist I
worked with many deadly reptiles up till
now I've always had a good understanding
of how each animal can kill me
using venom constriction power or teeth
this time I'm going after an animal
that's known to be deadly but how they
kill is still debated the Komodo dragon
I want to try something completely
different to investigate the Komodos
hunting style something that's never
been done before mounting a spy camera
on a dragon's back my Komodo cam may
just record a dragon catching prey but
first we've got to catch our dragon
Jerry says we can do that without a trap
but I know from previous experience it
will not be easy out here Komodos have
very little contact with humans getting
control of this beast will be a
dangerous maneuver
[Music]
snaring it is the easy part okay okay
two three okay you can get from the
behind subdue it I got a leap on its
back yeah ready yes on
I'm ready pad yeah you can't go ahead
I'm straddled mini Crocs but
pound-for-pound this lizard feels even
more power
okay I need some help it's a rope I need
some help yeah yeah yeah man I think
it's strong started in the crocodile if
one was the anymore
put your hands on on his I well we
caught a dragon oh man this thing so
powerful this is a good candidate for
our camera gone cuz he minis heavy it
spread here right here this is good this
is good what let's go to to play the big
wizard the camera is not the only
equipment the dragon will need to carry
we'll have to mount a radio transmitter
as well this doesn't hurt the animal at
all but it allowed us to find the dragon
whenever we want to okay we got the
transmitter on the dragon is not happy
let's get this camera on and turn him
loose okay we've got a small recording
device and a battery which is attached
to our small spy camera
we'll attach it here between the
shoulders the camera will show us what
the dragon does it's a long shot but if
this camera test succeeds it could give
us a Komodos eye view of a hunt all
right we got our spy camera in place so
now we'll see what the lizard sees as
night falls the time comes to retrieve
our Komodo camp
hopefully the footage will provide the
clues we need Jerry's receiver will pick
up the signal from the transmitter on
the Komodo when we find it the plan is
to retrieve the recording without even
restraining the animal look big dragon
footprints maybe that's our animal he's
headed this way and that's big that's
bigger than my hand look at that
we're going in the right direction we
know that Jerry is picking up the
dragon's signal as the tone gets louder
we know we're getting closer we're very
close we have to be quiet we do not want
to wake this dragon out but something's
wrong
that's not our dragon
is there dragon
the recorder is gone box is gone is that
that's our dragon right you got this
mode shape it must have fallen off
the camera in the recording unit are two
separate devices the camera is still
mounted tight but the recording unit has
vanished it's a major disappointment
[Music]